hey guys welcome back to another video
and today is Thursday so that is a dev
stream recap day like always and there
is tons of season 4 news
with more coming in the next couple
weeks so let's not waste any time let's
get right into this
so first up they showed what some of the
hit with the two new heroes looked like
in their names our shaman and Aramis
so we're gonna go over them real quick
and kind of show what I think they're
gonna be like so the first character up
is our a mushi he's gonna be the hybrid
character for the samurai and he has and
according to his description he has fast
attacks seeing as he has dual katanas
and faint and counter-attacks he'll
probably be used a lot in his kit now we
don't have any movesets leaked or any of
that stuff so we won't entirely know but
that's what it says and as well he also
looks like Samurai Jack which is a
pretty big bonus I might have to use him
the next character up is the shaman
who's gonna be the assassin for the
Viking she wields an axe and a knife and
her traits at the top say that she is a
fast attacker with predatory and blood
trance now I'm not entirely sure what
these mean I've never seen any character
before but I'm assuming that she's gonna
have a lot of bleed attacks and then
she's gonna have some ability to stalk
her prey I was thinking about this then
maybe if she bleeds her opponent she can
see blood trails to find out where the
enemy went if they went running but
that's just my guess let me guys let me
know what you guys think of these
characters these look badass
let me guys know what you got let me
know what you guys are gonna use as your
mains when in season 4 rolls along I'd
love to know and then since every season
you get two characters in two Maps the
maps also look very nice as well the
first one is market town which kinda
reminds me of the first mission of the
samurai campaign I'm I may be wrong
though but I believe that it's correct
and it also has a zip line where you can
travel throughout the map quicker next
up is gauntlet which is the Viking map
there wasn't much showing about this and
I don't believe there's a new trap or
anything but it does look amazing and I
have to admit the design team did very
well with these maps as usual the heroes
are gonna be released for season pass
holders on November 14th along with the
beginning of season 4 and then all
players will be able to play with them
on November 21st a week after the season
pass players now for the maps though
gauntlet the Viking map is limited to
every single game mode except skirmish
and market town is limited to every game
would accept Dominion just in case you
want to know why that map isn't in the
rotation or not so that was really the
end
the new stuff a lot more stuff is gonna
be talked about I'll get to that later
in the later in the video so stick
around for that
but that's gonna be the end of the new
season stuff as of this week but there
is a new things that you guys might want
to know about that are very interesting
the discount for the masks outfits are
now 20,000 steel it's over now they're
not 20,000 set at 15,000 steel so you
can still buy those but just they're
gonna be a little bit more expensive the
content of the week is ornaments they're
about 5,000 steel I'm not gonna show the
video I'm only gonna show a little
tidbit just because I want to dedicate
most of this video to the season 4 stuff
and then in general news in the next
patch heroes are going to be able to use
for execution instead of two so instead
of having y and x we're gonna have Y why
a hold X and then X hold so we're gonna
be able to have 4 executions instead of
the original 2 which is amazing if
action war is also gonna be getting a
huge rework that wasn't really mentioned
but that'll definitely be talked about
in the next couple weeks hopefully it'll
make it a lot more enjoyable to actually
play faction more but we'll have to see
on that and then patch notes are also
going to be released next week for us to
read the last really quick thing that
they have was a bunch of patch note
highlights there wasn't too many though
but it said that no HP regain went on
the last bar of Health so that's gonna
be eliminated out of stamina means you
will not be able to interrupt enemy
light attacks rolling will not make you
immune to guard breaks and charging
attacks no boo she's blissful rest is
gone and replaced with second wind
smoke bomb will now stop enemies from
interacting with objects such as tribute
flags and Dominion zones and feats such
as second wind are interrupted so those
are gonna be the new patch highlights
obviously there's tons more stuff coming
with the launch of season 4 that will be
talked about and I will cover that for
you
but there was one post that Eric Pope
the community director did talk about
and I wanted to share this with you guys
this isn't this did not happen this week
but it will be happening next week it
wait next week on the Warriors then
we're gonna be seeing a lot more hero
trailers we're gonna see the full
versions as well as going into a deep
dive with the art team and seeing how
they made the new maps the new gear and
to customize the new heroes we're also
going to be getting new executions soon
so that's going to be nice as well as
dedicated servers coming in coming there
soon as well as bunch of hero balance
patches so that about wraps up the video
guys thank you guys for watching this
video boot please be sure to stick
around for next week there's going to be
tons more information this was more of a
teaser for the info we're gonna be
getting tons more next week and once
again I'll gladly cover that for you
guys like I always do either way thank
you all for watching the video and I
just want to say a really quick thing
thank you guys for 3,000 subs it's a
really small number compared to all the
bigger channels on for honor and stuff
like that but I hit 3,000 like just
about a week ago and I'm super happy for
all that thank you all for the new
people as well it was super grateful I
feel so thankful for you guys me the way
like the video if you guys did enjoy
subscribe before you need to for honor I
do a lot of news discussions leaks and
whenever that stuff comes out especially
now since season 4 is just right around
the corner my two most recent videos are
popping up on the screen if you did miss
those and with that guys I'll see you
all later have a great rest of your day
and peace out